if to test it
one way to one way to test it is to pull
this piece off
and just hold up your ear and see if you
hear it
one two three four five one two
i'll get you another cable
oh guys gotta hustle
okay brian you there okay
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
somebody
[Music]
every man wants to be
[Music]
he's a macho man
[Music]
hey
i
hey
me
[Music]
he's
hey
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
my
[Music]
[Music]
who
[Music]
it ain't me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no i never knew you at all
[Music]
and it seems to me
[Music]
[Music]
to love you
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and it seems to me
[Music]
when the rainbow
[Music]
[Music]
legendary
[Music]
no i never do you at all
more than just
[Music]
you're
but i was just
the candle burned down
[Music]
i pray you'll be armed
[Music]
[Music]
in times when we don't know
let this be our prayers
when we lose
lead us to our place
to place
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
from
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
just like every child
[Music]
give us
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
do
[Music]
is
[Music]
you turn my face to the door
just before dawn through a silence
you feel you could cut with a knife
announces the cat who can now be reborn
and come back to a different
evangelical life
[Music]
me
[Music]
memory turn your face
[Music]
[Music]
if you find there the meaning of
what happens is
[Music]
memory
i was beautiful then
i remember a time i
knew what happened
[Music]
[Music]
a smoky
a street lamp dies on another night
[Music]
daylight i must wait
for the sunrise
i must think of a new life
and i mustn't
[Music]
the forgive comes
[Music]
the trees in the sun
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
if you touch me
you'll understand what happiness
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
it's nine o'clock on a saturday
a regular crowd shuffles in
there's an old man sitting next to me
maybe love to his tonic and gin
[Music]
when i worry on the mat's clothes
sing us a song you're the piano man
sing us a song tonight
well we're all in the mood for a melody
and you've got us
feeling all right
[Music]
now john at the bar is a friend of mine
he gets me my drinks for free
and he's quick with a joke or to light
up your smoke
but there's some place that he'd rather
be
[Music]
he says i believe this is killing me
as a smile ran away from his face
well i'm sure that i could be a movie
star
if i could get out of this
[Music]
now paul is a real estate novelist
who never had time for a while
and he's talking with david who's still
in the navy
and probably will be
[Music]
and the waitress is practicing politics
as the businessmen slowly get stoned
yes they're sharing a drink they call
loveliness
but it's better than drinking
[Music]
sing us a song you're the piano man
sing us a song tonight
well we're all in the mood for a melody
and you've got us feeling all right
[Music]
it's a pretty good crowd for a saturday
and the manager gives me a smile
cause he knows that it's me they've been
coming to see
to forget about life for a while
[Music]
[Music]
what are you doing here
[Music]
[Music]
melody and you've got us feeling all
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
can you feel it coming in
[Music]
but i don't know who i am
[Music]
i know
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
i know the reason why
me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
but committed no crime
and bad mistakes
i've made a few
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
we are the team
[Music]
we are the champions
of the world
i've taken my bout
and my
no pleasure crew
i consider it a challenge
my friends
[Music]
are the champions
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
donald j trump
[Music]
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave that light to me and i gladly
stand up
next to you and defend her
[Music]
god bless the usa
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new york to la where there's pride
in every american heart and it's time we
stand and say
[Music]
that i'm allowed to be an american
where at least
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
[Music]
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
[Music]
well thank you very much thank you what
an honor
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you very much thank you
we love this section of the world it's a
beautiful section
we appreciate it very much and i'm
thrilled to be back in the great
commonwealth of pennsylvania so much
[Applause]
this is the state where the story of
american independence began
it's the state where the american
constitution was signed think of that
and three days from now this is the
state
that will save the american dream
on november 3rd we're going to win
pennsylvania and we're going to win
four more years in that very beautiful
white house
we're gathered today in a very special
place
in the harrowing days of december 1776
when the american revolution
seemed lost general george washington
made his headquarters
at this bucks county farmhouse to plan
his famous crossing of the delaware
on christmas night he led what remained
and just uh remained very little
remained
of that ragtag continental army on a
daring
midnight raid it was a tough night it
was a violent night
they marched through nine miles of ice
and snow
many without boots on their feet leaving
a trail of blood in their wake
at dawn they seized victory at trenton
their sacrifice turned
the entire tide of the war those
soldiers came from
every walk of life but what united them
all was their devotion to the principle
of
self-government they were determined to
live in a country where power belongs to
the people
that priceless inheritance is at stake
just three days from now
and a great red wave
is for me
[Music]
i'm sure you're there as sure as we're
here together that wave is forming and
they see it they see it on all sides
and there's not a thing they can do
about it
[Music]
this is the fundamental question facing
every voter
in america do you want to be a
nation ruled by the corrupt political
class
or do you want to be governed by the
american people
i ran for office four years ago because
i could not sit by and watch
any longer as a small group of
washington insiders continue to get rich
bleeding american dry
you're just bleeding america dry think
of it
closing our factories opening our
borders outsourcing our industries
and letting foreign countries ravage our
middle class
career politicians spend trillions of
dollars fighting foreign wars
while letting our own cities crumble and
decay
here in pennsylvania you know this
bitter and very painful betrayal
all too well better than most
the corrupt washington class launched an
economic war against
this state for decades they targeted
your steel mills
shut down your plants and sent millions
of your jobs overseas
all while lining their pockets with
special interest cash
and no one embodies this betrayal and
treachery
more than joe biden
so
[Music]
and worst of all the suppressed
media and big tech
refuses to cover the crime
they refuse to cover we've learned so
much
over the last two weeks for 47 years
he supported every disastrous trade deal
that enriched his cronies and
impoverished your state
he wiped out pennsylvania steel he was
the cheerleader for nafta and china's
entry
into the world trade organization
pennsylvania lost 50 percent of your
manufacturing jobs
after those biden disasters then biden
pushed
the job-killing paris climate accord
economic nightmare for pennsylvania
miners
and every worker in our country he
backed
tpp which would have extinguished the
american auto industry
forever forever
these betrayals not only made biden's
donors rich
they made his family rich and as we know
he profited from the misery of unleashed
work and horror given to
pennsylvania workers he he made a lot of
money and his family made
a lot of money and nobody and nobody
knew about it until just recently
at the debate i looked at him and said
joe you were here for 47 years
and you left only three and a half years
ago
why didn't you do these things that you
want done
why didn't you fix it joe
and as you know because i assume
a number of you watched the debate
but as you know he just looked at me
and shrugged
in fact the anchor looked up and said
why did you do it
she couldn't believe it she was on his
side she said why didn't you do it
why did you do it and why did you say it
in 2016 pennsylvania voted to fire this
failed and
corrupt political establishment and you
voted for an
outsider as president who is finally
putting america first
and if i don't look like a typical
politician
that's very simple it's because i'm not
a politician
if i don't always play by the rules of
washington and the washington
establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you and i fought harder for you
than any president in the history of our
country
from day one washington insiders have
been trying to stop me
because they do not own me and they do
not
control me they want control they don't
like
what i'm doing they don't like what i've
said to
the big pharma the drug companies
the number one lobbyist in the world
number one lobbyist in our country they
didn't like that i instituted favored
nations so that we now pay the lowest
prices in the world for prescription
drugs
instead of the highest prices in the
world
if these corrupt forces succeed in
electing joe biden
washington will see to it that another
outsider
never becomes president again it'll
never happen again
and nobody has done in three and a half
years
nobody no administration no president
what we've done
and what we've accomplished and it's not
even
nobody even challenges them
they'll take back control and they will
never ever
give it up this once in a lifetime
opportunity to beat the corrupt
politicians
will be lost forever and they know it
they're fighting so hard
and they hate what they're seeing
because they're
not looking at fake suppression polls
anymore
now they're looking at the numbers that
are pouring in
and they don't like the numbers that
they're seeing in florida
and in ohio and in north carolina
[Music]
and we think in pennsylvania although
those numbers come in late
we think in pennsylvania they
they don't like it they don't like it
they don't like what they see
and i just want to tell you that we have
uh really
uh things have worked out so well for
our country
nobody had any idea nobody had any idea
that anything like this could ever
could ever happen if you look at
what's going on with over the last four
years
we've been building the biggest
strongest
and most secure middle class in human
history
we built the most powerful military
anywhere in the world
and over the next four years we'll make
it even stronger
stronger like nobody thought even
possible
do not be intimidated by our opponent's
angry and menacing tone
because if we were we would never have
been able to accomplish
what we've accomplished in truth they
are actually terrified of you
the people they're terrified
you're terrified that you will discover
that you have the power
to end their corrupt rule once and for
all we have to do it
when you see what's going on we have to
do it we don't have a choice
somebody said do you enjoy this i said
it's not a question of enjoyment
believe it or not i do
i shouldn't have to go check something
but i shouldn't
but uh you know today we're doing three
rallies
tomorrow we're doing five and the
smallest crowd will be
25 000 people
then on monday we're doing five or six
and i can't tell you what's going to
happen i think we'll just go home and
rest
but they don't get to decide this
election this is your choice
we have to be very careful but to be
very very careful especially in this
state
more than any other state they say you
have to be very very careful what
happens in philadelphia
we have to be extremely everybody has to
watch vigilant
your decision your future is at stake
as your president i don't answer to the
special interests have no interest
in me i don't take instructions from
donors and lobbyists
i don't care about them i don't care
about them
i don't take my orders from the media or
as i affectionately call them the fake
news media
and as you know they've turned out to be
far more fake than we ever thought
and they've really turned out to be
corrupt
they are corrupt they are really corrupt
the word fake is not strong enough
especially after what we've seen
where stories major stories the biggest
story anywhere in the world
is absolutely not covered it's hard to
have scandal
when you have no coverage and they work
in conjunction with
big tech and they protect each other and
they protect the democrats because with
the democrats you don't have somebody up
talking like i do about them so they can
do whatever they want and it will only
let
this will only lead to very bad things i
do what
is right for america i do what's right
for america
it's
it's made me a lot of enemies in
washington
but i wear their opposition as a badge
of honor
winston churchill once said that it was
a nation
that had the lionheart i had the luck
to give it the raw i gave it the raw
and there is a roar and people hear it
all over they heard it
they heard it four years ago loud and
clear probably
the biggest thing to happen they talk
brexit they talk
many you know numerous things but this
is always number one what happened
2016 and i will say 2016 was an
incredible
earth shaking event but 2020 and i never
thought i'd say this
2020 what we're doing right now
through tuesday what we're doing is far
bigger
it's far bigger i never thought i'd say
i never thought four years ago and you
never did either somebody would say that
this is going to be
this is going to be the most important
election
perhaps in the history of our country
it's really amazing
the greatest threat to american
democracy is the concentration of power
among a small group of
unelected special interests the big tech
ceos who have been put in a position
by us giving a law to them section 230
we've given them that power
and you know that can be taken away
that can be taken away and probably has
to be taken away
i see it better than all i see it i see
it so obviously i see it because of
what i do on social media for me it's
very easy to see i see things that
nobody would believe
the corporate media and the mega donors
in washington and silicon valley
they're all lining up behind an opponent
that's going to do whatever they tell
them to do that sleepy joe biden
it could have been the greatest you know
if you look
uh we look at the amount of money that
he
has raised hundreds of millions 300
million dollars one month
but i could have been the greatest of
all time i could have been the greatest
political fundraiser
because as president all i had to do was
call wall street
the big banks i could have called the
oil companies i could have called
all of the big companies and every
single one of them and i know
many of them would have given me
whatever i wanted
but i chose not to do that and we did
plenty
we have we have plenty we can only buy
so many commercials you know
when the airwaves are full and you can't
buy anymore
i'm saying where are we going to spend
it although we did spend in our case a
lot on
ground game which they i think forgot
this
much money as they have they're
screaming in florida where's our ground
game where's that guy well it takes a
long time
you know what it took us took us a year
and a half to build that ground game so
we'll see how it all works out but they
didn't do that they decided to go a
different route
but they took in massive amounts of
money i could have taken in much more
than that they did 350. i could have
done that within an hour
the president is calling he'd like you
to send 25 million dollars
please who's going to tell me now nobody
but the problem is
the problem is when they call in six
months needing a favor that's worth
billions
it's very hard especially me being a
loyal person
not a dishonest person but a loyal
person is very hard for me to say no i
don't want to take his call
no his or her call no i don't want to do
it
so it really your compromise it would
have compromised
our nation so i didn't want to do that
joe biden works for them i know them
very well i know them far better than he
does
i know him far better than me some are
friends some are actually very surprised
when i say you don't have to bother
don't worry
i don't think we can buy anymore anyway
right but he
he works for them and when you see those
numbers 300 350 million so much they
don't know what to do with it
where they're spending 25 30 million
dollars on a congressional race that
used to spend
five hundred thousand dollars you know
something's going on
and it's not a good thing and it's not
the way i want to work
this was one opportunity to do something
special this isn't a company this isn't
making some money this is one
opportunity
to turn our country around and we're not
going to blow up
so he works for them not for you and
it is i who work for you i am working
for you it's like
not used to that too much but i've
gotten used to it
and we have this great opportunity
together and
our people tend to vote in particular
state you tend to vote on the third i
could say go in an
early vote don't wait till tuesday vote
today vote tomorrow
vote on monday but i'm wasting a lot of
time because you want to go
it's tradition it's habit it's it's the
history of this state look at what
you've done with this state look at the
history of this state
with respect to our country and you want
to go so i won't even say go
today go tomorrow go the next day or go
on the third
we want election day thank you
election and we have others like that
too
we have others like that too they won
election day it's going to be a great
day the more
these corrupt forces oppose me the more
i know
we are delivering real change real
progress
and historic victories for the american
people
we have done great things with the
country including our military
our vets the biggest tax and regulation
cuts in history
we just received a poll this was a real
poll not a suppression paul where the
vets
gave us a 91 approval rating for the job
that we're doing
think of that 91 percent the highest
half
over these last four years we've been
building the strongest and most secure
middle class in human history we have
built the most powerful military in the
world by far
nobody has ever built what we've built
and when i came in we had a depleted
military we had old flames we used to
get parts by going to the
airplane graveyards and taking the old
parts out of all planes that were
sitting there rusting in the sun
and uh crazy weather where they store
them in the deserts
and that's what we were doing we had a
depleted
terribly depleted military and now we
have
the best equipment anywhere in the world
by far all made in the usa
as i say we are the envy of every world
we are the envy of every world power
from china to russia and north korea
they look at us and they say wow what
they've done
new jets new fighter jets bombers
tanks missiles rockets nuclear
and just hope to god we never have to
use it hope to god we never have to use
it but
it's less likely that we'll ever have to
use it when we have it
okay when we have it we were in very bad
shape militarily
a general came to see me highly
overrated general came to see me
actually
one of the world's most overrated
generals and he said sir we have no
ammunition right at the beginning you
know what i'm talking about
because we could have had conflict he
said sir could you hold it off we have
no ammunition
and i said general no president should
ever hear that statement again
we have no ammunition well now we have
so much ammunition
our problem is we have no storage
and over the next four years we will
make it even stronger
going to keep us safe last night our
brave special forces rescued
an american hostage in a far away
now
incredible people and i was in fort
bragg yesterday and i met
a lot of the incredible he's incredible
talented
strong both physically and mentally
the strongest the best in the world but
we had a
mission sent to a far away land where
the
kidnapped an american citizen and
the kidnappers wished they had never
done it
and they went in with a large group zero
casualties
we got our american citizen young man we
got our young man back
but the other side suffered gravely i
can tell you
our nation salutes its courageous
military
which brilliantly executed this
operation
very few people would have been able to
do it it was very complicated a very
complex
tough area we celebrate the safe return
home
of an american hostage we've gotten many
hostages home
[Music]
and i pay nothing nothing can't pay once
you pay
you'll have many many more your 40 you
know robert o'brien is doing a
tremendous job said to me so you're 48-0
48 and i'll think of that we've brought
many many of them all
some mostly in pretty good shape some in
very very bad shape
specifically you know who i'm talking
about came home in very bad shape
but sometimes that happens to but we've
brought many home but we don't pay
you pay once you pay your numbers will
go up
a thousand-fold we're boldly standing up
to china we achieve the most secure
border in american history our southern
border
we have attained in just a short period
of time american
energy independence and if we're up to
the opposing side
with the green new deal the green new
dealers
aoc plus three and you add pelosi and
schumer and you add
joe biden who really doesn't understand
sea doctor probably
he'll tell him what to do he'll do
whatever they tell him whatever it takes
he'll say whatever it takes
with the sunglasses or the sunglasses
i said i don't think i'm going to do
that but i watch those sunglasses
i don't know to me it didn't work
we're bringing our jobs our factories
our wealth and our troops all back home
they're all coming home
they're all coming on and instead of
endless wars and countries that
even you very sophisticated people in
some cases have never even heard of
we're achieving one historic peace deal
after another if you look
middle east we already have three signed
up we have many countries one assigned
we're signing them
rapidly and even with uh kosovo and
serbia we're doing a trade deal with
each
a routine trade deal when i heard about
it i said wait a minute
they've been killing each other for
decades they've been killing and killing
for decades each other
fighting all the time we're doing a
trade deal they want it
they always want us all of them want us
the whole world wants us so we're in a
great negotiating position
but i said kosovo serbia we're doing a
trade deal
you tell them we're not going to do the
deal unless they make peace
and all of a sudden they were hugging in
the oval office
that's great
and it came through common sense that it
came for no money
couldn't make a trade until we said no
we're not going to make the deal unless
you
two start getting you're killing each
other for decades and decades that's all
they do is they
kill each other and when i saw the two
leaders hugging in the oval office and
there was a
i mean i think they were exhausted
frankly i think it was time
it was time but somebody had to say do
it just seemed to make a lot of sense i
said
wait a minute let's do it and we did it
so i'm very
happy about that and thanks to our
administration's
unprecedented mobilization
we're now just weeks away from the mass
distributing of
a safe vaccine where really and we've
got it
we've got great companies johnson and
johnson moderner
pfizer all all with the vaccine you all
with the different little different
versions of it some similar some similar
concepts
but and many other companies and we're
we're ready we'll have that
and uh and we will have it but even if
you didn't i say when i say it drives
them crazy we're rounding the chair and
we're rounding that turn surrounding us
and our economy went down less than any
economy anywhere in the world
and it went up faster by far you know
they keep hearing about europe europe
europe well they're not
doing nearly as well seniors will be
first in line for the vaccine
and the vaccine will be free because
it's not their fault
it was china's fault china did this to
us
and our vaccine will eradicate the virus
and end the pandemic once and for all
americans will return to school
and to life
by slashing red tape and cutting
bureaucracy
we're producing this vaccine in record
time
if joe biden were president you wouldn't
have this vaccine for four years
and he had his chance with the h1n1
he calls it swine flu
which was a disaster we've moved heaven
and earth to produce the vaccine ahead
of schedule and manufacture
hundreds of millions of doses in advance
all ready to be
shipped and we have our military's going
to be
shipping it logistics we have a general
that's what he does he delivers troops
he says sir this is easy we get it done
very quickly
it's the most advanced medical operation
anywhere in the world and in history
thanks to the therapies we've
accelerated we have already reduced
the mortality rate 85 percent
think of that down 85
and our excess mortality rate is 40
lower than europe's and europe has done
a good job it's a very brutal thing
everyone thought germany was doing great
great great great
they're not doing great right now you
see what's going on over there with
france again spain and italy
but we're doing great but we just don't
get credit for it we don't get credit
and i don't want the credit personally
but i want the generals and the admirals
and
our great vice president mike pence who
works so hard
and all of the people on the task force
and
and jared kushner what he did he's here
someplace
but he was fantastic on the ventilators
you know ventilators are very very
complex
oh look at that jared he and he wants no
praise he just he couldn't care less
he truly couldn't care thank you jared
no we had a tremendous vent though just
a quick start we had a tremendous
ventilator problem because we weren't
equipped for
a thing like this this is once in a
hundred years
1918 we're talking about the spanish flu
and we we weren't equipped for that and
all of a sudden we're getting calls we
need 40 000
ventilators like in new york they needed
far less than that but they needed many
many ventilators and other
states are calling we need ventilator
and it's a very
complicated piece of equipment as you
can imagine with pipes going down
heavily computerized and people didn't
know
what to do making them on a mass scale
like this hospitals had very few of them
and jared called up some of his genius
friends his brother's one of the most
important people in
silicon valley smart family they called
up and they had these super
brilliant young men come in i mean some
of them were wearing undershirts they
were wearing a vest
they're wearing a baseball cap how much
are you worth about a billion dollars
sir
so they've founded companies sold their
companies but they were brilliant
one of them had roller skates on
and they wanted to throw him out of the
white house they said
so there's a kid here undershirt and
roller skates i said yeah he's worth two
and a half billion dollars
buddy jared called a whole group of
people down
and to them to us to all of us a
ventilator is very complicated
to them it's like the simplest machine
they've ever seen
and they went to uh the automobile
companies where they had excess
plant capacity and they went to various
companies and
we started producing within a short
period of time
ventilators and this story is just never
told and i don't think i've ever told it
not in this detail
we started producing ventilators in a
short period of time
at a level that nobody thought was
thousands and thousands a month nobody
thought was even possible
and a relatively short period of time
after that all of our hospitals were
sent
tens of thousands of ventilators tens of
thousands
of ventilators great companies very big
companies
car companies very big companies they
did a fantastic job
they'd line up with a small ventilator
company
and we make the best ventilators i mean
they say they're the best and
they were sent all over our country and
think of it
and that was done so quickly but these
brilliant young people were able to do
it
regular people could i mean you could
never do a thing like this
so we made thousands a month and not one
person think of this in our country not
one person who needed a ventilator
didn't get a ventilator how incredible
is that
but they won't tell that story that's
not me that's jared and a whole group of
very brilliant people together with the
military and with
a lot of our great companies we've had a
tremendous relationship
it's the biggest mobilization since
world war ii and uh it was an incredible
job now what we're doing
is we're making we continue to make
thousands a month and we're sending them
to foreign countries who are desperate
for ventilators
and would have no idea there would be no
way they could ever get them
including i mean we send them to france
and we send them to
spain and italy but we send them to
countries in africa
who are really having a terrible hard
time
and we're sending thousands of them to
other countries and i just think it's a
tremendous story
and it's something that we did that
we're very proud of
and it's something that nobody talks
about you don't hear about you don't
hear the word ventilators anymore
you know why you don't hear about it
because we solved you know there was a
period of time
ventilation for three four five weeks
until they
sent these super geniuses and for three
four five weeks all you heard about was
ventilators
ventilate well you know we took over
something the cupboards were bare
they were bare or essentially bare but
they were bare
and the hospitals and the states the
cupboards were bare too nobody was
prepared for a thing like this they
could have been they should have been
but now all over the world we're sending
them and i think it's just a tremendous
story i really do
it's a story that that's untold you'll
probably never hear about it again
and as soon as we started making all of
these thousands of ventilators you
haven't heard the word ventilator
just just like and there's one other
quick story the wall the wall the wall
that's all you heard
trump promised the wall will he ever
give the wall the wall the wall
and then now the wall is going to be
completed very quickly we have over 400
miles of wall
and now you never hear the word wall
they never say oh
he got the wall he did it and we built
it exactly
to the specifications of the border
patrol
and they were tough specs i will tell
you i said how about concrete plank no
sir we need steel we need rebar and we
also need concrete oh that's great
but we got it built and they have to
have vision they have to have slats
because they have to be able to see
through what's on the other side you
can't have it you know once you
realize this they're right so we built
it to those specs
very very uh i've done an incredible job
we're doing 10 miles a week
we'll be finished very soon but you
never hear about the wall anymore
you know now it was a failure if we
couldn't get it done
it would be brutal it would be a brutal
time for your president
because of our relentless efforts the
recovery rate
right now on covet or the china virus
or the china plague is 99.7 percent take
away
99.7
and i'm here i'm here
[Music]
i'm here are these two great people
whose property we're using today it's a
what a historic property
and all i know is they said we just
drove up the road they've been here a
long time
but not as long as george washington but
they've been here a long time and
they said and you probably many of you
said do you see the crowds
it looks like broadway except it's
slightly more picturesque
slightly more picturesque but it's
thousands and thousands of people lined
all the way
down to the highways it's incredible and
they're all waving plants
most importantly they're all waving
flags and they're proud of our
nation
i guess it has something to do with
pennsylvania i'm going to be here all
day today
but no it's a beautiful sight and they
were very proud and thank you very much
for everything you've done
we're allowing younger healthier
americans to resume normal activities
while strongly protecting
the elderly and those at high risk and
we're
making the powerful antibody treatment
that i receive
available to anybody that needs it free
free wasn't their fault
but i had that and i didn't feel good i
said what's going on
test positive and i couldn't i'm the
president of the united states i
couldn't burn myself in a basement of
the white house as nice as it
is i actually got this here one time
it's very nice
like you would expect it's a beautiful
basement it's in the white house
very solid basement but i couldn't do
that and i couldn't
put myself in a beautiful room upstairs
beautiful bedroom and stay there for a
year and a half i'm the president
and i go to meetings i'd say that's a
lot of people
and then one day that happens
and i said i wasn't feeling good and
what
the doctor came in and great doctors
great white house doctors shown
and they came in and they said sir
you've tested positive i said test a
positive for what
and they said for covin for covert he
actually used the term covet
he's more politically correct than i am
i said that's not good but i didn't feel
good and uh
we went over to walter reed medical
center which is phenomenal i see the
work they do in young men coming back so
badly
and women so badly wounded i see
what they can do what they can do and
nobody can do what they can do
johns hopkins was great we had a lot of
doctors gathered around but i didn't
feel good and
they gave me something regeneron
and eli lilly makes a very similar kind
of a thing the concept is based on
antibodies
and i woke up the next morning and i
felt so great i wanted to rip that
superman shirt open
i wanted to come back
i wanted to start doing a new trade deal
and campaigning
simultaneously they said they said sir
how about taking it easy for a couple of
days but now it's incredible what we've
been able to do is
and i don't even know maybe you know now
i'm saying well probably
wasn't the drug it's just that i'm in
such perfect physical condition
and i'm very young you know if you're
young
so i said that and cnn got very a bit
right there
the camera just went off they're like
they got upset they said he is not young
and he is not in perfect shape i said
i'm a great physical specimen and they
they didn't like it when i said that
they they don't like they don't like
those kind of things no but you know i
don't i don't know maybe uh
i helped i don't know but i can tell you
it's incredible what they've been able
to do
and i think it did help a lot frankly i
got out of there fast i could have gone
out a lot sooner too i want to go out
almost immediately visit nice and easy
please sir
and but it shows you maybe i serve as an
example
first lady got it also and she's better
she's perfect
[Music]
and barron trump right aaron
baron got it my young boy is 14 years
old and
my young tall boy i say is very tall
he's a good guy
good looking guy and strong so he has
it's his sister
baron tested positive also i said
then i go this was at the beginning i go
i say to the doctor about like
12 minutes later doctor how's baron
doing oh he's okay sir he sloughed it
off
i said he's you know why they're young
and the immune system works that's why i
say
get back to school
get back to school open up open up the
state
governor open up this state
and don't take advantage of those
ballots governor don't do it
don't do it we will terminate the virus
with science
medicine and groundbreaking therapies
and cures
i watched joe biden speak yesterday all
he does is talk about covet cover he's
got nothing else to say kovac kovetkova
we agree
we agree it's serious that we we've done
an incredible job
and at some point they're going to
recognize that at some point you know i
said
we've done an a plus job but we give i
give ourselves a d
or maybe an f in terms of public
relations but now i'll start talking
about it a little bit
when joe biden was vice president his
failed approach on the swine flu was
as i said a total disaster and his chief
of staff said that
he had no idea what he was doing i don't
know why this guy said this
and now they're thinking about bringing
him into the administration i guess
probably this was maybe before the flu
came along or something because i'm
saying
why would he say this he goes quote
we did every possible thing wrong
and 60 million americans got h1n1 far
less lethal by the way far less lethal
and in that period of time and it's just
purely
fortuitous that this isn't one of the
great mass
casualty events in american history this
is fighting steven's death think of what
he said where did this guy come you're
going to bring him back
it had nothing to do with anything we
did
we didn't do anything right now think of
this
then he's saying we want to take over
what you're doing right he says we want
to take over
remember he said when he first started
running
that i did a poor job because i didn't
act fast enough i acted in january
with almost know death don't think of
this and i said
china is heavily infected they can't
come in and i went up against
dr fauci and others that said no no you
shouldn't do this
you shouldn't do it i said listen
they're infected heavily infected let's
close off china so i did that i closed
off europe i did that
same and fought you would tell you save
tens of thousands of lives much more
than that
and then when you think okay i mean we
saved
thousands and thousands of lives and
then biden is campaigning
and he was two and a half months later
he said we have to get tough and he
called me xenophobic because i closed
two and a half months later then he runs
and he said he should have closed the
country earlier
i said i don't think he's going to get
away with that and let's see what
happens on november 3rd because if
something happens that's wrong or he did
then he did get away with that now
here's a guy
not the smartest guy out there and he
never was but now in particular he's not
doing too well
but here's somebody that says that i
didn't act early enough
and for two and a half months he was
scolding everybody
saying that they shouldn't have closed
off china they shouldn't have done
and that nothing bad is going to happen
but remember the statement from his that
was his chief of staff made that
statement
we mourn for every life loss to the
china virus and in their memory
and their sacred memory we truly do we
weep
we mourn it should have never happened
we will defeat the virus and emerge
stronger and more unified than ever
before that's all we can say
we're going to be more unified than ever
before
our economy is now surging back faster
better bigger and stronger than
any nation on earth we just had the best
quarter
of economic growth ever recorded
ever recorded by more than double
a 33.1 increase more than
a great number from 1952 that was the
number we bet but more than double
and you know what the press is refusing
to talk about it's not even a major
story
it was one of the analysts said today it
was the greatest economic
number that they have ever seen okay gdp
up 33.1
that means it grew 33 in in a short in a
quarter
and the press barely mentions it not
even on the front page of
newspapers because that's the game they
play at suppression
that's why we have to win we can't let
them do this
we have to win this was according to a
certain very important person and larry
kudlow who's a terrific guy
and other people sir this is the
greatest financial number probably ever
recorded in our
country think of that that's a big
statement and
double more than double a number from
1952
and it's barely covered and that's only
for one reason
because they want us to do very poorly
on november 3rd they don't want to tell
the american public about this
the one advantage i i do have is i do
have
a way of getting the word out but it's
very tough
very tough when they pick it up even
this they won't pick this up i made a
statement
strong statement they won't pick it up
because it's good news
they'll fabricate stories they'll make
up false stories they'll put you number
one on twitter all the time twitter
stories that aren't trending these
stories are so boring
they'll make up the times or write for
all stories all the time
and they'll put them and yet they won't
talk about the biden corruption
they won't talk about where's hunter and
they won't talk about
they won't talk about don't feel bad the
cameras are all off don't worry they
just
we just lost the last camera i'm sorry
but they won't talk about the fact that
hunter got 183
000 a month to sit on the board of
barista
and got 3 million dollars perhaps three
million dollars up front they won't
who had no jail who had no experience in
energy they won't talk about the fact
that the
wife of the mayor of moscow
gave him three and a half million
dollars
right for what they won't talk about the
fact that the father went to china and
air force two
whereas hunter was with michael i put
his first name his real first name is
where we're gonna make it
where's hunter was with him and in 10
minutes he walked out with one and a
half billion dollars to manage which is
millions of dollars in
fees millions and millions and they
won't talk about the fact that he was
going for the big one next with china he
asked for 10 million dollars a year
for introductory purpose in other words
he was going to introduce people
10 million a year this is a payoff
that's all it is
and they won't talk about the fact that
the father
was the big guy to me he's not a big guy
really very very he's very he's very
slight
remember when he said a year ago he said
i'd like to take him to the back of the
barn
i went like this
i'll take him to the back of the bar
the glasses
next year will be the greatest economic
year in the history of our country if we
don't raise taxes
if joe biden is elected he will delay
the vaccine
prolong the pandemic close down schools
and
impose a nationwide lockdown that's what
they're talking you imagine going
and we're making the greatest comeback
of any country by far
and they're actually talking he's
talking about a lockdown he has no clue
but he's talking about it that's his
only plan
to make you a prisoner in your home a
prisoner in your own country and
under the biden lockdown the recovery
will be totally killed
the economy will crash country can't
afford it
the people can't afford it but country
can you imagine
i mean your state has to open up too
all democrat governors you
michigan north carolina i mean they're
all democrat governors
and they're probably doing it because
they want to affect the election
you know they're probably doing it by
november 4th they'll announce we've
decided to open up
pennsylvania the commonwealth of
pennsylvania will be opened on november
4th
no because it can't be they can't be so
stupid what they're doing to people
and the countless people that will die
from depression
and drug overdoses and suicide and abuse
and really a deferral of medical care
there'll be no school there'll be no
graduations
there'll be no weddings no thanksgivings
no christmas
no easter's no fourth of julys
there'll be nothing will be nothing
and you know one thing we've learned
very recently where everyone likes the
computers and the laptop and all we can
learn from the computer you don't have
to go well now we've
given it the all-time mass test right
a child being in a classroom or if
you're
old or a campus even a college campus
but a child being in a classroom cannot
be replaced by a computer
you can't it doesn't work it's no good
and they're losing you know potentially
years out of their life and it's
the important years it's the development
years but the computers don't work
they're okay but they're a small
percentage and that's come out loud and
clear
telehealth great it's been incredible i
think it's a 7 000
increase percent and telehealth has been
really great
she's going to have a great future but
not education
they have to be in their classroom with
other students
and they have to find their way in life
and no future
this is no future for what they're doing
in pennsylvania what they're doing in
other
states this is no future for american
youth it's going to have a long-term
impact on them
biden's plan will destroy america my
plan will destroy the virus and make
america greater than it's ever been
and the skyrocketing cases in europe
have shown
draconian lockdowns and that's what they
are the draconian
do not stop the virus they've done it
italy was so
locked down now it's starting all over
again they just don't it's a terrible
thing that was unleashed on
us and we should never forget what
happened
we should never ever forget that china
could have stopped it
they stopped it from going into the rest
of china but not from going to europe
the united
states and the rest of the world we can
never forget it
but the far left is determined to lock
down america because
what they crave more than anything else
is power
and control over you joe biden has made
a corrupt bargain in exchange for his
party's nomination
he has surrendered his party to the
radical socialists
left-wing extremists
anarchists looters today's left
tolerates
no challenge and allows no dissent
you see that they have it locked they
have them locked down that's the
ultimate lockdown
you can do horrible things or you can do
nothing wrong and they'll put in
phony stores i'm actually a victim of
the opposite i'm just thinking about
well i'm talking to you they do phony
stories that are totally false
and they put them up and there's nothing
you can do there's nothing you can do
except
explain it away if you disagree with
them
they try to humiliate you smear you
and cancel you cancel culture right
they control joe biden and he's so easy
to control
just like they control every democrat
house member in every senator
they purge newsrooms of reporters who do
not
swear allegiance to their false
narratives
you've seen some reporters are extremely
upset they end up getting
absolutely decimated they censor stories
that reveal
the corruption of their chosen candidate
this is what's happened now and nobody's
ever seen anything like
it everybody knows that it's
it's incredible nobody's seen anything
like it you don't read anything you go
to the times there's no story in it you
go to the washington post
you go to abc you go to
nbc the worst of all in my opinion and
recently
the home of the apprentice made them a
lot of money over the years
right but they were bad they were very
bad cbs
has been terrible cnn is just absolutely
ridiculous
thank goodness ab lousy ratings thank
goodness
and and ms i call it msdnc how about msd
no what they do is just absolutely it's
not even thinkable
it's not even to be believed they
totally
close it down and you can't have scandal
when nobody's reporting about it
and the level of power is pretty
incredible
and i heard this four years ago sir you
cannot compete
with big tech you cannot compete the
networks were against was the same group
and then i won i said see they're not
very powerful but you know what they are
and now they're at a level that nobody's
ever seen before
nobody and they're blatant about it now
they just say
we're doing it we don't new york times
they apologized to their subscribers
because they were losing
tens of thousands of after the last
election
tens of thousands of subscribers and
they wrote a letter of apology i
couldn't believe it
and they really got good for about two
weeks
and then they got worse than ever i mean
it's every day a phony story after story
after
they have a story about taxes i don't
pay taxes
and and i just call my people what what
do they
oh no you paid many many millions of
taxes sir but you prepay your taxes
oh well why aren't they mentioning i
prepaid
millions and millions of dollars of tax
i prepaid that's worse than
paying taxes i'm prepaying
i say why do we prepay so much because
these are estimates
when you're negotiating taxes these are
estimates you're prepaying estimates
how much many millions of dollars
millions and millions
but they don't do that we call them we
tell them and they say well that's
prepaid well prepaid is
worse than right i mean how good is that
we're prepaying
but they don't put that in the story
these are very corrupt
very dishonest people they tell you that
rioters are peaceful protesters
because you're not allowed to have i had
it yesterday in minnesota where we had
we're going to have over 25 000 people
and the governor of minnesota radical
left
democrat and the attorney general they
said no the most you can have is 250
people to my people they said that
and so my people said so we're going to
close it down with thousands of people i
don't know you probably all saw it last
night
tens of thousands we're going to have 25
30 000 people
and don't forget they've done a terrible
job in minnesota where they let
minneapolis burn
down and they could have called us a lot
sooner we went in took us about what 25
minutes to solve the problem
no we could have gone in there we were
willing we called them we willing to go
there immediately instead of having
everybody running away
and they have a very good police or they
had a very good police force
but they don't let them do what they
have to do and
they shut it down they said no you can't
have 25
000 but you can have 250 people
and uh i said to my people now let's go
let's speak in front of the 250 million
what i didn't know is that thousands of
people were going anywhere
they just won they just went
and i think that had i done a regular
rally with
because we're getting 25 30 000 people
getting much more than that at some
nobody's ever seen anything like this
laura ingram had a show last night she
said i've worked for everybody i've
worked for reagan
and nobody's ever seen anything like
what's happening it's a great thing it's
an incredible thing this is supposed to
be a little special speech but
it's you've never seen anything like it
nobody's ever seen it
and what happened is i think because of
what they did when they said we're going
to silence his voice
it turned out to be a much bigger voice
and i think we now
are going to 1972 minnesota hasn't been
won
between omar ilhan omar
who as you know comes from minnesota i
think omar a couple of other things the
riots
but i think what happened is they made
this into a massive event
and people are tired of it and i think
we will
win minnesota we're very close last time
and we should win it when they let
minneapolis burn
we should win it but i think we're going
to win it and again 1972 was the last
time can you believe that
i think we're going to do we'll find out
you're going to know it about well i
hope
based on the supreme court they don't
delay it too long this decision
yesterday
i will tell you it was not a good
decision
you're allowed to wait days to count
and days to have the final cut you're
allowed to
have time limits beyond november 3rd so
what does this mean
the whole world and our nation is going
to be waiting and waiting and waiting to
hear
who won yeah they're going to
you're going to be waiting you're going
to be waiting for weeks
and a very dangerous thing happens
november 3rd and now you have to wait
and wait and very bad things can happen
with ballots during that period of
november 3rd
to whatever date they gave them many
many days
so you're going to be watching on
november 3rd it's i think it's highly
likely you're not going to have a
decision because
pennsylvania is very big and as you know
there were
there was another state but perhaps
other states involved
this is a terrible thing that they've
done to our country
and that's the united states supreme
court i'm talking about that is a
terrible political horrible decision
that they made
we're going to be waiting november 3rd
is going to come
and go and we're not going to know and
you're going to have bedlam in our
country
and you're going to have this period of
nine days or seven days or whatever it
is
and many bad things ballots are going to
be oh we just found 10 000 ballots oh
that's good
we just found another 10 000. this is a
horrible thing
that the united states supreme court has
done
to our country and i say it and i say it
loud and i say it proud
we have to know who won we have to know
who won
they tell you the police officers are
villains
this is the group and they're heroes no
they even tell you that your children
must be indoctrinated to believe that
the heroes who cross the delaware were
driven by
hatred and malice change your history
a vote for joe biden is a vote to give
this radical movement
absolute power and unchecked control
over
every aspect of american life joe biden
who's not he's not all there should get
a little bit of larger frame don't you
other you know i know there's less you
got to get a little
i'll tell them he doesn't want to have
people look at
that surgery on the eyes joe biden and
the socialists left
are absolutely convinced of their own
moral
superiority i don't know if he is
because but they are
they are he isn't look let's face it
he's shot same time
who said that
it was exact timing right
you copied me from another space
while their agenda devastates the poor
and
the american middle class will be
devastated
they support crippling shutdowns that
crush
the blue-collar jobs while they
stay home and work they close down your
schools your children while they hire
private tutors for their children they
ban you from
going to church while they let left-wing
extremists
burn down your church
you can only meet if it's a protest so
you know what we do
like even in this day i'm i call this a
protest
otherwise they don't let you move you
can't go to church right you can't go to
church what they're doing
to our churches and our synagogues and
all of that is just terrible you see
what's going on even when the church
wants to go into a field and stay
apart they say no you can't do that you
know it's like a terrible thing
they lecture you on the need for open
borders that flood your cities with
illegal drugs and gangs while they
themselves live in walled off
compounds they wanted to fund your
police and confiscate your guns
simultaneously why they
themselves are protected with armed
guards no we will protect your second
amendment 100
there is only one way to preserve
protect and defend
the american way of life you must show
up
on november 3rd okay
don't worry about the first or second
because i know
i know you too well the biden harris
economic policies of increasing taxes
and regulations
biggest tax increase in the history of
our country is what they're proposing
would pulverize our middle class their
plan is projected to hammer the typical
american family's income by over six
thousand
five hundred dollars a year in the wall
street journal by contrast i cut taxes
and regulations at a level nobody's
ever done before and raise middle-class
families incomes
over six thousand dollars in just three
short years
and that's not including energy which is
a tremendous
what we've done with energy is
tremendous joe biden has pledged a four
trillion dollar tax hike
socialized medicine an avalanche of
job-killing regulations a return to
globalist trade deals and he vowed
at the total destruction of the
pennsylvania oil industry
and fracking fracking is gone
fracking is gone and he said that loud
and clear for a year
until he realized that he has to win in
pennsylvania
but fracking is dead because their side
it's dead you saw aoc go out and say no
no no you can't say that when biden
switched and he never had one question
from the press
how could you say it for a year and then
all of a sudden switch when you walk
into pennsylvania
now fracking would be dead joe biden's
plan to abolish american energy
is an economic death sentence for
pennsylvania
a vote for biden is a vote to ban
fracking
and to send your state into a nightmare
of poverty and depression that's what's
going to happen
it's your single biggest industry by far
probably a million jobs one way or the
other
and what it would do to a country
because our country has low energy costs
you and texas and others think of texas
he's running in texas we're doing very
well in texas but if you believe the
fake news they'll tell you oh it's very
close it's not close at all and it
wasn't close four years ago
think of texas it's very close he's
against oil
he's against guns and he's against
religion
and then they say texas is very close
think of that right it's against oil
guns and god
texas is very close too close to call
i don't think so i think texas texas is
going to be very strong for us
can you imagine going into texas say
we're going to take your guns away and
by the way we're going to close up every
oil
well that you have vote for me vote for
joe
i don't think so i don't think so if
biden wins there will be no fracking no
oil
no natural gas no jobs and no future
under biden gas prices will explode
family incomes will plummet and the
fracking industry will be outlawed
forever
forever with your vote i will cut
middle-class taxes
even more i mean we cut them at the
highest level in the history of our
country even when you saw what it did
that's why we're coming back so quick
because we have a strong foundation a
base and i will always defend and
promote
pennsylvania energy and there will be
no more lockdowns we're not going to
have lockdowns
we will never lock down again joe biden
would appoint the most radical left-wing
cabinet
in history beto o'rourke will be in
charge of gun confiscation
elizabeth pocahontas warren will be in
charge
of the united states treasury according
to what they say
aoc plus three will run the climate
policy i wonder if she ever even took a
course
and climbed it i don't think so this is
the
i didn't say it you did this can only
happen in pennsylvania don't forget
i went to school here you know he was
sort of he likes to throw around the
pennsylvania thing
look at it differently he abandoned
pennsylvania he bet
he went to delaware but i'm not blaming
he was nine years old or something so
we can't blame him for that right but he
left pennsylvania now i went to school
in
pennsylvania as you know representative
ilhan omar
will be running homeland security how do
you like that
who knows i just said that one but you
know what
i wouldn't be surprised ladies and
gentlemen we're pleased to announce
ilhan omar to run national
she's security to run she's going to be
guarding our border
where we just had the best numbers we've
ever had by the way people can come into
our country we want them to come in
they have to come illegally and they
have to come in through merit
just imagine the insanity that will
ensue if pelosi is speaking
schumer is crying chuck majority leader
kambalaharis
she makes bernie sanders look like a
very strict
conservative you have kamala
got to say the name exactly right and
they excoriate you
do you have kamala running the white
house
well she already said that right she
said that it's the
harris biden he actually said that was a
scare he said under the harris i never
did that i never said
under the pets trump administration and
i love mike pence you know what
but i said mike that far we can't go i
know
but he said you know he made a mistake
he also said he's running for the u.s
senate two or three times
he said i'm a proud democrat this is
like three four times
i'm a proud democrat running for the u.s
senate i want you
and we said no joe you're running for
president oh okay
is this whole thing i mean can you
believe that this could only happen to
me
and how are you doing we're tied we're
tithed how the hell
how can i be tied we're tired
he said four times the other thing he
does badly haven't done it yet i hope i
never do
but he'll be making a speech in ohio
ladies and gentlemen of iowa it's proud
to be
the worst is when he's making one in
miami with the palm trees
the beautiful palm trees ladies and
gentlemen of
ohio no no he's made that many times and
you know what i always say
winston churchill was a great great
orator right amazing order
amazingly because he was a stutterer in
his life he was a stutterer
i became a great orator you could give a
speech
equal to the best that he's ever made
and if you made the mistake in saying
welcome like we're in pennsylvania
it's great to be in new york
it doesn't matter how good your speech
is it's over just walk off
it's over but he does it all the time
and nobody even says
no he's shot under my leadership
we achieved and he's not a nice person
you know what if he were a nice person
they do commercials on me that are so
false
like with the soldiers that's the
biggest insult to me of anything
that's probably ever happened like with
the soldiers
and other things they're so false based
on a phony magazine
an obama type magazine that's doing
badly
they did a commercial there were and we
notified them and we had 26 witnesses
real witnesses and every one of them is
furious
but he's not a nice person so because
he's not a nice person i don't mind
saying exactly what i'm saying
which as you know is the truth he was
never considered smart in his prime
but now he's really off
and you can't have him as your president
because he'll destroy our country
he'll destroy our country and it
probably won't be him because by the
time he gets sworn in he'll be pretty
much like it'll be over
25th amendment do you think they were
talking about me no they weren't talking
about me
when she brought that up they're talking
about how to get kamala in there as fast
as possible
and nobody treated him worse than her if
you looked at the bait takamala was
failing fast you know she was going down
like a rock
normally you pick somebody that's going
up not one she didn't even make
it to iowa right but nobody spoke worse
about him and that's the one that they
picked
but they want to get the radical left
they'd love to get her in and that will
be
a very i don't know i don't know if you
can ever come back from a thing like
that you know i'm not sure that
a country you look at venezuela you look
at what's going on where it was the
richest
it was so great 20 years ago and now it
they don't have food they don't have
water they don't have medicine
under my leadership we achieve the most
secure border in american history
the wall biden's plan to admit unlimited
low-wage foreign workers will slash
incomes
surge unemployment and devastate the
middle class
all to enrich the globalist donors
as president my only special
interest is you that is true my only
specialty
to protect our national security i also
suspended the entry of refugees from
foreign nations
compromised by terrorism just call up
president macron as i do often and ask
him
what's happening over there you saw
those horrible attacks this last week
more than one we're keeping radical
islamic
terrorists the hell out of our country
if i have your approval
biden has pledged a staggering 700
increase in refugees this is a deal made
between biden
and bernie sanders crazy bernie the
manifesto we call it there's a document
a very thick document
naming things that they're all horrible
but they've agreed 700
percent increase in refugees from the
most dangerous and violent terrorists
hot spots anywhere on earth including
syria
somalia and yemen
these are some of the most dangerous
places in the world
700 increase this is agreed to this
isn't like oh
this is talk this is a manifesto
it's a document he's also vowed to
terminate our national security travel
bans allowing for
unlimited migration from war zones and
terrorist havens
biden's extreme migration policies will
open the floodgates to terrorists
jihadists and violent
extremists you don't have to worry about
it just get out and vote on november 3rd
under my administration you know i had
the ban passed right
and it was approved by the united states
supreme court there they did the right
thing
under my administration the safest of
our families will always come first
that's safety we want safety
has to come first the secretary of
defense under president obama robert
gates
said that joe biden has been on the
wrong side of every foreign policy issue
in his lifetime
president obama used to say that if you
wanted something really screwed up
give it to joe biden to handle
this is the guy that we have running in
fact
obama tried to keep joe from running he
was
very famously quoted as saying joe you
don't have to do this
you don't have to do this joe don't do
it you don't have to do this i could see
that
and then wouldn't endorse him until long
after the primaries had ended
and joe is lost think of it he wouldn't
endorse him he was a vice president
wouldn't endorse he made all these
terrible statements wouldn't it go so
and then even after he won it was months
before he endorsed him
because he didn't want to see it happen
i think he's probably the most surprised
person on earth
obama and they said sir
obama's going to start campaigning for
him couple of days ago i said that's
okay that's good he campaigned
for hillary how did that work out
and his crowds are uh extraordinarily
small just so you understand
they're not big like 22 people 18 people
for months joe biden and kamala harris
have been inciting violence against
police officers and riots
like those carried out by biden
supporters in philadelphia look at
what's going on at philadelphia
they should call us into philadelphia
we'll solve the problem or
let their police handle the problem let
their police handle the problem
if elected the democrat ticket will pass
legislation to end cash bail
create sanctuary cities nationwide and
to fund police departments all across
america
in a second term we will increase
funding for law enforcement
we will hire more tough on crime
prosecutors to put
violent offenders behind bars
for 47 years joe biden betrayed
african-americans at every turn he took
your votes he took you for granted
and then he shipped away your jobs and
flooded your cities with cheap foreign
labor he devastated black families
with his 1994 crime bill that locked
really locked up tens of thousands of
african-american men with unfair
sentencing and he called
african-american young
men super predators all the time he
would say super predators
a name that has always been something
there has been no name that
they've hated more they hated it with
hillary clinton and they hate it
with joe biden super predator the term
super predator that was his term he
forged close relationships with
pro-segregation lawmakers and
his trade deals decimated the black
middle class
joe biden cares more about refugees
living
thousands of miles away that he does
about black america's
living in philadelphia milwaukee detroit
baltimore
oakland he's done nothing and then he
says to me oh we should do this
i said joe again always so easy
47 years but he left it was only three
and a half years ago
so this wasn't a long time ago i
reversed the injustice of biden's crime
bill by signing
landmark criminal justice reform prison
reform
and under our recently announced
platinum plan we will create 3 million
new jobs for black americans
increase access to capital restore
safety
to every neighborhood and we will
deliver school choice to every parent in
america
and i'm also fighting every day for
hispanic americans this week i announced
our american dream plan
and we're doing very well with hispanic
americans you see that they're saying
what's going on in florida right
they like me and i like them and we're
doing very well with
our with the black community they like
me
now they're getting to know me better
but i've always liked them
the american dream plan which creates
over half a million new hispanic-owned
small businesses
and jobs and going to be fantastic for
our hispanic americans great people my
administration
is also standing proudly with the people
of cuba
nicaragua and venezuela in their
righteous fight for freedom
biden-sided with the brutal socialist
and communist
regimes you saw what he did you said
that horrible deal that was made with
the united states
by obama and biden i don't think biden
probably was too involved you won't know
the truth keep him out
but it was a terrible deal or was it
like the iran deal he's 150 billion for
nothing
as long as i'm president america will
never be a socialist country
will never be
[Applause]
this year i've laid out the boldest and
most ambitious second term agenda in
history
we will create 10 million new jobs in
the first 10 months
2021 we will have 10
million jobs over the next four years we
will make america
into the manufacturing superpower of the
world
we will expand opportunity zones we will
bring home our
medical supply chains through all coming
home and we will end our reliance on
china once and for all
we will defend religious liberty the
right to life
and the right to keep and bear arms
and we will restore patriotic education
to our schools
in our debate last week joe biden said
that
america has quote never ever lived up to
our founding ideals right
and he said it was an idea it was just
an idea that america no
america is a great country the united
states is a great country it's not an
idea it's a great country
pennsylvanians know the truth more than
most when you think of the great history
of this state
from washington's crossing and
independence hall in philadelphia
to the quakers who ran the underground
railroad
from the union soldiers who lay at the
rest and you lay at rest they lay at
rest in gettysburg what a place
gettysburg one of the most beautiful
places and so gruesome for a period of
time never fight uphill my boys right
he said never fight uphill me boys never
fight uphill they fought uphill
to the workers of bethlehem and
allentown who forged the steel that won
world war ii america is the
story of everyday citizens who have
given everything to help this country
live up
to the highest ideals my fellow citizens
you deserve
a president who believes in america a
president who loves our country
and a president who loves you
everybody knows that joe biden is not
equipped
to lead america to republicans
democrats and independents across this
state
across this nation i'm asking for you
to honor me with a vote that's going to
make our nation
greater than ever before
[Applause]
[Music]
i will continue to fight for you with
every breath in my body
and with your support on tuesday we will
show the world
that for our country and for our
children
and for the incredible people of
pennsylvania
the best is indeed yet to come thank you
very much
[Music]
young man there's no need to feel down
[Music]
[Music]
it's
[Music]
but you've got to know this
[Music]
to the ymca i'm sure
[Music]
they
hang out with all my boys
[Music]
[Music]
someone came up to me
ymca they can't stop